I told everybody I was like [ __ ]
unplug me if that [ __ ] happens don't
even wait 30 seconds
I want to be here going hey
but then like you can't
you can't I'm like this but inside I'm
like
[Music]
what do you guys what do you guys think
of this place right here take a look
this is Sardinia Italy
that was like a lot of color correction
in the photo hey wow okay jeez you don't
think it's naturally like that you think
they just turned up the saturation
ah yeah dude so this is starting to show
my dreams yeah you guys like it they are
gonna pay you 15 grand to move here shut
up
nope day one day Warners there I thought
Italians were like Italy only get the
[ __ ] out but it costs like 30 000 a
month to live there or what no it's not
expensive at all the only there's
there's a few catches we'll get to that
there's um there's a there are places
where they just need people you know
like they just don't have people yeah
they just don't have people like you
can't build infrastructure you can't do
goods and services there's just not
enough they have a population is it
directed is it directed towards like
tech people or like you know services
like you know what I mean sometimes
they're they like when crypto was huge
they wanted specific crypto people to
move to different countries in order to
help like bring economy to that land in
that way I didn't know that I'm pretty
sure it's not crypto people they want
yeah I'm guessing so too but I'm just
wondering like if so people are let me
let me tell you uh let me tell you a
little bit about what it takes uh if
you're gonna accept this offer all right
you uh you gotta move to one of the
towns in Sardinia that has a population
of Less Than 3 000 people yeah so you
got to go to the small that's like going
to high school again
Italian girls are hot so if I was single
all day yeah yeah they were all probably
all related to each other three thousand
three thousand people dude yeah and then
um so the 15 000 that you get you don't
actually get it you have to put that
entire total towards renovating the home
you buy there
that is an interesting cash I am
suddenly off the table but keep talking
all right and
relation the third one is you gotta live
there full time so this has to just be
where you are like forever yeah I can
understand they would do that or you can
go on a vacation it probably means
whatever the uh residential requirement
is for like maybe like how many days out
of the Year true because to be a Nevada
resident you had to be like 140 days or
something like and if you do if you take
this offer you have to register the
place as your permanent residence within
18 months that's pretty that makes sense
give up on Sardinia you know Sardinia
failed you know certain cities don't
make it it's like let's let's go
somewhere how about that what is the
thing about Sardinia you know what I
mean like you know some cities like this
is known for like phenomenal seafood or
like all the [ __ ] come here because
it's just great for Instagram not with 3
000 people yeah
that's where sardines come from that's
why they were invented man but what
would you do for work though Ken
sardines people have three thousand
people to sell to
us
with shopping remember there's like some
of the whacker states were doing [ __ ]
like that too like Kansas or something
they're like come over here really here
it'll give you like 20 G's you want to
move over here I know we're whack but
here's some money have you ever seen an
incentive like that that was a good idea
I've seen people like they sell houses
where they're trying to give good
incentives but not like that not like a
whole thing like that they're paying you
to hack kids in Japan
they're paying you to have kids how much
do they pay you oh I don't know don't we
do that in California with the welfare
system that's true if you know how to
work the welfare system you guys know
about the baby motels right
Vapor motels like so like baby making
motels oh so if you are a citizen of
American citizen but you're Chinese
they'll pay you to go move in a new
community so they can fly in uh pregnant
women so they can have their babies in
America so they're paying people to live
in certain communities these pregnant
women walk up and down the street
because you know when you walk it speeds
up the you know the baby process so they
pay you know if you're a Chinese person
you know who's a citizen it's easy to
buy a home here and they buy the home
cash and then they fly in dude we saw
one of those homes we were looking to
buy a house in the area there was that
back room that had beds next to each
other is that what that was yeah that's
what the sounds that's what they said it
was yeah yeah so that might be that's
when they pay they'll pay you like hey
if you're they'll run ads in China you
know like if you have family members
that live in America and they'll buy you
the house they'll buy you the house
they'll want you to live there full time
like it's pretty much a lot of those
rules and they'll send all these
pregnant ladies those are not just one
they send like herds of them and then
all you're doing is just servicing them
by making sure that food make sure you
know they need a ride to the hospital
you know so because if they're if their
kids are born here they're citizens to
get way better how do you get in contact
with these people Realtors there's a lot
of rules a lot of Chinese Realtors
everybody wants to come to America damn
and they talk so [ __ ] on America but
then they want to come to America
that's the commercial for America dude I
love that everyone wants to come to
America except the Scandinavians they
like it out there better I think they're
better off yeah no one no one's
interested in this offer
you lost me I put the 15 grand into the
house here's one thing that's cool about
it
um but you could get new tile though
just at least into that sentence they
got good time
okay they have the world's highest rate
of inhabitants that are 100 plus years
old okay you know that is amazing it's a
Blue Zone it's a blues maybe this offer
will be available when we're like 60
though you know what I mean I think
Italy in general has like people more
than Okinawa no that's a Blue Zone too
there's a few blue zones all over the
world that has a lot of centennials
because I thought miso soup was like the
key to life but I guess sardines are
sardines are man what's a blue Zone a
blue zone is a concentrated area that
has a lot of centennials oh so like
they're they study that area and they're
like what is it about their lifestyle
and then they came out with a few
factors of long life it's Community
um diet you know activity physical
activity activity things like that I
guess in Italy with all that carbs wow I
guess it's good carbs would you even
want to be 100 years old
if I love my life yeah but I like think
about 90 to 100 those 10 years how
shitty well 85 82 I think yeah like by
that time do we have like Professor
Xavier [ __ ] like [ __ ] moving around
you it's yeah it depends on technology
and your sentience depends on the
condition I'm in so I've seen some
capable like 90 100 year olds and then
there's like these new [ __ ] 120 year
olds and [ __ ] popping out now these
[ __ ] are so stretched out now
they're so stretched out dude their
[ __ ] eyes are like this have you seen
them we're like the insides are coming
they're like skeletons like there's
imagine how dry your [ __ ] eyes are
yeah if you're [ __ ] insides are
showing or if like the inside of your
mouth is [ __ ] shoulder I don't want
my insides coming out but what if but
what if you don't feel that anymore you
know what I mean you know you don't feel
it yeah you don't feel it it's not
something and plus like you're like 100
years old you don't actually give a [ __ ]
nah he felt dry man
you got to feel your eyes sag for sure
I'm definitely I'm more of a pull the
plug kind of dude like I'm with you you
know what I mean like I wouldn't want to
be a burden on my family I don't want
anyone paying for like a nursing home
but what if you're like that one old
Japanese grandma that's like 90
something still doing triathlons and
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's different that's
different you won't die like if you have
a [ __ ] to me if I was 60 years old
and I'm like this and just in the bed
all day I'm like kill me [ __ ]
yeah so it's not the age it's really
like yeah how I don't know how much yeah
those people like those are the type
people that you if you put anything
wrong about them they would go is that
all you got like they just won't [ __ ]
I think this as soon as you can stop
wiping your ass you gotta I think that's
yeah oh that's a good that's a good life
dude don't throw me in a donated bidet
right and [ __ ] catheter my ass and
get some VR on me and just leave me
alone for like 10 years oh [ __ ] man [ __ ]
you dude as long as I'm good just
[ __ ] put a tube in my [ __ ] damn he
wants that Wally life you know what I'm
saying well if I'm already there I'm
like What's the next level of existence
that's what Neil was in The Matrix man
turned me into a battery I'm probably
weak but you dude that might make you
young again because you're like
avataring it yeah and you're walking and
moving VR style so your mental like it's
like it's like it thinks it's you're
young and by the time hopefully the
future of technology like make the chair
move me you know what I mean so I'm like
anime but like it's not my choice yeah
you got like an exosuit that just does
everything yeah not bad it'd be fresh
man I definitely don't want to go down
as one of those like I'm aware of
everything but I can't move it's like
sleep paralysis for the rest of your
life like but then my family's still
caring about me I'm like oh [ __ ] there
you go dude I told I told everybody I
was like [ __ ] unplug me if that [ __ ]
happens don't even wait 30 seconds I
don't want to be here going hey
but then like you can't see that just
here
I'm like this but inside I'm like
you know yeah but on the outside you're
like yeah yeah
Uncle Joey's so happy yeah
and it had it like how does like I'm
gonna try I'm gonna try to uh see if we
can help you and maybe I'll give it a
year I'm like a year [ __ ] that [ __ ] so
I'm gonna count on all of you guys to
pull that [ __ ] that's probably
all of sardines just a ton of people
with plugs in the wall going out we're
gonna we're gonna be just around your
like bed and we're like alright guys
we're here it's been one year we've got
to pull the plug and then right right
there we're like
nah one more year
[Music]
man damn I think if I was in that point
where it was pull the plug I'd want to
go out like against I want to be like
thrown at a helicopter or something
exciting let's make a bang you know what
I mean like let the [ __ ] [ __ ] blend
you and [ __ ]
I think he's throwing out not throwing
up out and upside down helicopter
pictured a helicopter here and they
threw him off the hospital building and
they blend them on the top no I wouldn't
want like Santa somewhere like populated
just to like [ __ ] with people just to be
like is that an old guy flying out of a
helicopter and I just have that little
joy of seeing him like ah and then I die
like I would like to like just fill you
with helium and just let you kind of
float around would you land on the
concrete no the water oh okay yeah I'd
want to be I thought it was like at that
velocity and imagine if you don't die
suck it yeah what about what about like
can they just put you in an astronaut
suit and then just push you out to space
oh that would be a peaceful as [ __ ] and
then you and then you just have like
cyanide that you can chew if you get
bored from bored also you could kill
yourself you don't feel that just in
case just in case like it's like three
days you're really hungry you just been
[ __ ] yourself as you've been
floating in space you're like not even
close to the Moon
because it's like slow that would be
pretty tight to be launched into space
because like you know you have the
infinite possibility of being found one
day like
[Music]